today we remember lou gehrig on the very
first ever lou gehrig day in major
league baseball
as we continue to raise awareness for
als and look for a cure for this
insidious disease lou gehrig made his
big league debut on this day passed away
on this day as well we honor lou gehrig
throughout major league baseball robert
valdez gets the start for the houston
astros left-hander will be making his
second start of the season he took a no
decision against the padres only going
four innings through 72 pitches did a
great job while he was out there against
a tough lineup only allowing two hits in
one earned run looking to extend this
outing today hopefully against these
boston red sox [ __ ] hernandez since
coming off the injured list started 10
for 25 but now oh for his last 20.
carlos correa to his left makes the play
on hernandez robert valdez gets a lot of
ground ball outs and starts this game
with a groundhog alex verdugo swing and
a miss got it with a fastball down and
in for his first strikeout of the night
two outs in the inning slow this down
for you because that was a pretty wicked
two-seamer on her match for super mode
there you see the rotation and the
movement pretty impressive they're all
loaded up for a hunter renfro here in
the first inning and a golden
opportunity for the red sox there are
two out all filled up
and he's taking it's dropped and that is
ball four and a run is in here comes jd
martinez forced in on the walk and the
red sox take a one to nothing lead what
a gift he wasn't even close there four
times he looked like he tried to aim
that ball took off so he's walked his
second man in the first inning he nick
prevented a right-hander 6-0 with a
3-8-6 era's first career start at minute
maid dusty baker might dial up julie
guriel's name more often than not he has
incredible numbers with the bases loaded
as he bats here with the bases pulling
one out
fly ball to right field deep enough to
score altuve correa tags at second as
well he's going to bluff altuve will
score jordan
alvarez stays at first julie gurio with
a sac fly into right field ties up the
game at one a piece good professional
banning by julie guriel got a hair out
of place with that easy at bat and easy
rbi he's amazing getting runners home
from third with less than two outs i'm
telling you there is a certain knack for
guys that can drive runs in where they
can just smell it out and they just find
a way garcia just recalled on friday
from triple a correa at third alvarez at
second tucker at first
swing and a miss down he goes he gets
out of it with only the one run and
leaves them loaded three infielders on
the right here's the one two slowly hit
ground ball alex bregman will charge on
the move makes the play to get verdugo
by half-ish drive played by alex for the
first out of the inning jd martinez
ground ball towards correa carlos backs
up on it makes the thong throw and a
pick at first base by eule guerrielle we
usually see carlos correa pretty
aggressive on ground balls coming to get
it but decided to back up a little bit
and it ended up being an in-between hop
that he was able to snag and turn and
make a decent throw but a lot of credit
to yuli guriel going out there and
scooping that for him to protect carlos
correa and get that out for from valdez
here's xander bogarts swing and a foul
tip caught by maldonado one two three
inning for fraumber valdez picking up
strikeout number three to end the inning
robbers now retired seven in a row since
the base is loaded walk i'll bring a
mile straw a little tapper here comes
tucker trying to score he will the play
to first draw out at first base but
tucker scores the go ahead run kyle
straw a little check swing rbi ground
out to make it two to one that was such
a good read by kyle tucker now granted
with one out you're usually running on
contact this turned into almost a
squeeze type play and if kyle tucker
isn't anticipating that ball down he
doesn't get a good jump like that but he
did a great job getting that read and
getting miles straw and rbi tough inning
right here altuve correa and bregman
foul tipped and that one held by vasquez
he struck him out one yeah finish him
off with that high cheese man it works
every time bunch of sliders fastball up
and away got some jump on it he can hit
a high fastball but not that high a
little foul tip so number eight for
pavetta pitch number 96 coming here from
pavetta
breaking ball
devers got him two up two down bregman
trying to make contact against pavetta
line shot coming on is [ __ ] to make the
catch on the run and pavetta gets them
in order in the fifth inning two to one
houston of the 16 outs for fraumber
valdez he has seven strikeouts swing and
a miss got him with the curveball xander
bogart strikes out for the second
straight time eight strikeouts for
fromber and two outs here in the sixth
inning good curveball down and in and
this is exactly what he wanted to do
start it out make it look like a strike
and then break it down out of the zone
so now fromber will face hunter renfro
swing and a miss fromber valdez with
nine strikeouts tonight got him with the
breaking ball kind of explains why he
has that smile on his face out there to
work that seventh as you see the line as
it stands with him on the mound getting
ready for the seventh inning four hits
one earned run nine strikeouts did a
good job of commanding the baseball
after that rough first inning 2-1 top of
the 7th inning bobby dalbeck
ground ball towards the hole backhanded
by robel garcia off-balance throw in
time great play
by the astro second baseman robel garcia
that is a huge play
in the grand scheme of things for
fraumer valdez to be able to throw that
90th pitch
and get an out on one pitch to start off
this seventh inning and it took a great
play by rebel moving to his right going
away from first base and showing some
arm strength enabling himself to get
bobby dowell back it was a great play
get a fist pump from carlos correa
you're doing something right
2-1 lead for the astros top of the
seventh valdez trying to complete seven
here's the three-two
swing and a miss he got him tk hernandez
goes down on strikes at his strikeout
number 10 for fromber valdez one off his
career high and seven gutsy innings
coming back in his second start off
injury danny santana who started the
first two games of this series at first
base will pinch it for dow back swing
and a miss he got him big strikeout for
presley
two out to the ninth filthy slider
started it on the inside edge and then
snapped it off the plate and santana
could not lay off
good battle between santana and presley
presley wins out those two former
teammates presley knows where the weak
spot is santana former minnesota twin
christian arroyo do up two outs that
tying run at second base
pop up on the infield
should be the ball game correa puts it
away
astros hold on to win it 2-1
they have taken the first three games
for the boston red sox they have won
four in a row since that tough loss on
saturday
and plummer they've also ensured a
winning home stand with their fifth win
of the home stand that's another good
win against a good team